our guest today on the interview is the
author hamid abdul samad he's one of
Germany's fiercest critics of Islam and
he says to the Chancellor Merkel has got
it wrong when she says that Islam
belongs to Germany I made Abdul Samad
thank you very much indeed for joining
us here on the interview at Deutsche
Welle and I'd like to say a very warm
welcome to to our international audience
now hamid abdul samad you were you grew
up in Egypt and your father was an imam
in a in a small Egyptian village quite
close to Cairo I'd like you to take us
back to that time and tell me about your
earliest memories of growing up as a
Muslim I grew up as you mentioned in a
conservative Islamic family I was
learning the Koran by heart until I was
12 years old between 4 and 12 years old
I was learning the Koran by heart and
was brought up in a very conservative
way like many young Egyptians in these
surroundings when you say in a very
conservative way was that something that
you that you warmed to or was that
something forbidding for you as a young
child it was something forbidden I you
just have to imagine how a child could
learn the Koran by heart between 4 and
12 it means actually besides school 6
more hours per day memorizing the Koran
and learning which means that you didn't
have a real childhood you have to be
committed to the Quran it means that you
learned to appreciate the beauty of the
Quran I did I mean the Quran has very
beautiful sides I like the language so
much is very emotional very powerful and
very poetic parts of it and I don't
regret learning the Quran by heart it
helps me now to deal with the Quran from
a critical point of view are you still a
Muslim today I don't define myself
through religion not in a positive sense
or not in a negative sense I don't say
I'm a more
I don't say I'm an ex-muslim I don't say
I'm a believer I don't say I'm a
unbeliever I'm a human being and I want
to push that first and I wish that
people who are dealing with the issue of
religion that will put their religion
back and push the human being first so
that we can come to common grounds
you're sounding very relaxed as you talk
about your belief there but I'm a little
bit surprised because I know that a
fatwa was issued calling for your death
in Egypt and you have been living under
police protection I want are you still
living under police protection yes I
mean I have to be relaxed otherwise I
cannot work I cannot think I cannot
write I know that there are plenty of
crazy people out there who maybe want to
see me dead but I try to imagine the
world to be a rational world and I try
to address not it's not so much it's not
but other writer I have to take care if
I will allow fear to come in I have to
modify every sentence I write I write
and I live from the freedom I left Egypt
to live in freedom I left Egypt to say
what I think freely and I don't want
those powers from the Middle Ages to
hunt me even in Europe or the United
States and try to silence me I refuse
this logic
therefore I try to act naive and think
that everyone is rational and I'm
writing this book to rational people
okay and the people who may or may not
be hunting you as you put it the reason
is because you have been a very
controversial figure in their eyes
you've made some very controversial
statements about Islam you've written a
number of books about Islam the latest
which is now being published it's called
it's difficult to translate the German
title but I'm going to say the case
against Muhammad yes I like this I'm ok
I have a translation things have been
the search I've been searching indeed
for an English translation and I didn't
know how to put it I was thinking of the
trial of Muhammad okay you put it in a
more general way the case against
Muhammad grab that we have a title for
the book and I mean another of your
books the prior to that was Islamic
fascism
that's very emotive you will understand
that yeah what exactly is the problem
that you have with Muhammad is it that
he was a man of religion and a warrior
the problem I don't have a personal
problem with Muhammad the Prophet
Muhammad your problem with Muhammad yes
the problem with Muhammad is the
position of Muhammad in our today's life
in the 21st century
I don't criticize only what he did back
14 centuries ago but his influence over
millions hundreds of millions of Muslims
today worldwide in today's world today
as well you have said you have said
Muhammad cannot set any kind of moral
example for the 21st century he cannot
he cannot a person who was waging Wars
who was living from waging Wars Muhammad
as he started to be a prophet since he
started to say that he's a prophet
didn't have a job he his money was
coming from wars from selling slaves
before that he had been a merchant he
had been a merchant until he became a
prophet then it became his job to be a
prophet and then to be a warrior and he
and his community were living from wars
you were living from the text that he
was imposing on unbelievers he was
living from assaulting the the tribes
caravans moving between Mecca and Syria
I cannot consider a person to be a role
model who was married to nine women at
the same time I cannot have a person as
a role model who was executing hundreds
of war prisoners who surrendered to him
in the same day I cannot
have somebody as a role model who who
married a six years old girl while he
was over 50 years you clearly believe
that Islam in the 21st century needs to
be reformed needs to be modernized will
it be modernized I don't believe is lamb
can reform itself I don't believe in the
reform ability of Islam I believe in the
reform ability of the thinking of
Muslims that's how it is
you cannot strew the Quran until it will
fit to our time but you can convince
people that these verses of the Quran
the good ones and the bad ones are to be
read in the context of the seventh
century before doing that we have to
forget the idea that Quran is the last
Word of God sent to the human beings
this is the serious problem of the Quran
not what is written in the Quran but the
position of the Quran in our today's
society just like Muhammad is not what
he said said or dead back then but the
power he is having today as a role model
and if we can put those two things aside
Muhammad and the Quran to bury them back
into the age they belong to then we can
talk about the reform ability of
thinking then we can interpret that
verses in a modern way but as long as
they are from God Who am I who are you
to come and screw and correct God this
is the big question of course for many
people many Muslims around the world for
millions and millions of Muslims
Muhammad is a role model in the 21st
century in it included in that that
number are the many millions of Muslims
living here in Germany Angela Merkel at
the beginning of the year came out and
made a statement she said Islam belongs
to Germany and you came out in response
to that and you said from Merkel you've
got it wrong I mean Angela Merkel all
she was doing was saying to the Muslims
in Germany you are part of our society
you are welcome in this society with
your religion what's wrong with that
it wouldn't have been wrong if she said
Muslims are part of Germany I'm a
Democrat and I believe in the freedom of
belief everyone can practice his
religion the way he wishes but there is
a problem when you identify Muslims with
Islam one to one because when from
Merkel is saying Islam is a part of
Germany so is Sharia or can Sharia be a
part of German Sharia is a part of Islam
Muhammad is the core of Islam is
Muhammad part of Germany after all what
we know about him his Wars the way he
was dealing with women and the way he
was dealing with unbelievers of course
all these things that you talk about you
talk about Islam as though it's an
anachronism a thing of history but these
kind of quibbles I might say they would
apply to other religions as well yes but
which are the Christian country in the
world which is having it slow today
according to the Bible which is the
Christian country today which is very no
Germany which your journeys which
introvert is run according to the rule
of law and if people commit some of the
acts that you've been talking about that
will go against the law which is London
approach Islam is a part of Germany
jihad is a part of Islam Sharia is a
part of Islam the glorification of
Mohammed in the education in a part of
Islam by the way is a part of the Islam
preached in German mosques so then it's
not helpful at all to come and say Islam
is a part of Germany it's not the job of
changing it's a changing picture though
as you well know yes but it is it is not
the job of politician to rehabilitate a
religion or to make it a part of a
society or to dismiss about engaging the
religion in a description it is about
the people engage the people create jobs
for the people create a better education
for Muslims in Germany but don't say
Islam is a part of Germany because
nobody profits from that more than that
conservative Muslim organizations who
will come and say Oh
hey then I want to be just like the
German churches I want taxes from the
state I want to have influence over the
media I want to have influence over the
education and then you are selling the
secular state to the Conservatives on a
lighter note and to finish off I'd like
to we traditionally have free
uncompleted sentences and I'd like you
to complete them if possible if there's
one thing I have learned in my life it
is to appreciate freedom when I think of
Egypt I I have a crying eye and a
laughing I if I were to meet Angela
Merkel I would say again from Michael
you've got it all wrong
I will abdulsamad thank you very very
much for joining us here on the
interview on Deutsche Welle today thank
you thank you for having me